and a guy the other day said hey Ted I
really like your political views and I
went views we think the Constitution is
a view but rights like a hunch that I
have let me ask you this you know there
seems to be a huge difference I've
noticed this there are people like you
and the Alice Cooper's of the world and
even not even Rob Zombie like the hard
rockers or even as you go toward the
shock rockers tend to be more
working-class conservative as opposed to
kind of the elitists I don't even know
if you put in a rock but the people like
the Coldplay u2 there seems to be a
divide and I think people are often
surprised that Ted Nugent is Ted Nugent
or Alice Cooper is Alice Cooper could be
that's Alice Cooper right who'd have
thought he'd become a Christian
conservative there's a trend with that
do you think there's a specific reason
for that trend in in hard rock because
it's always fascinated me well it should
fascinate you because the media would
indicate otherwise 180 degrees otherwise
tell you and again I'm 68 and a half
years old getting ready for the greatest
tour of my life at the most outrageous
flame-throwing musicians and get third
place in every play playing the greatest
love songs in the history or what would
your life be like without Wango Tango
for example I don't know I might not
have a life why no tango could be
responsible for my birth well Steven you
Rimmer remember the baby boom yeah I was
bummed that was me any five point being
is that it doesn't come to a surprise to
me whatsoever going back with my band
alors we won the Battle of the Bands in
Detroit in 1963 we opened up for the
gods of thunder the Motown Funk Brothers
and uh and the the Stevie Wonder and
Diana Ross and The Supremes and I opened
up for Mitch Ryder the Detroit wheels
and Gene Pitney and Martha and the
Vandellas that's why I'm like this
Steven because I am so appreciative of
the blessings that I have been exposed
to and I've been able to cultivate with
my fellow working hard playing hard
musicians and let me tell you the term
working hard playing hard really really
describes successful musicians
work ethic we must focus and retain is
it
scare more people must be I will go out
this summer and I will play 60 some
concerts and I play six nights a week
and ferocious high-energy at my age I
should just blow up for the second spot
us I think Iggy Pop did that once I
think he actually did he was a case
study and spontaneous combustion yeah
well I save I saved my blowing up for
the Encore because I got no fan whatever
my song says eight crescendos my point
is it doesn't surprise me at all I know
these people let me in let me in let let
you in for a little secret that probably
won't surprise you but it's it is a
shocker the way I look at it I I'm not
gonna name names but I could name the
top artists on the planet who I've
worked with I've communicated with I had
a little red wine inversion Jarell
backstage we talked about every a make
possible issue that we references
quality of life the musical heritage of
the black heroes that inspired all of
our great music I love wolf Muddy Waters
B became Freddie King James Brown Wilson
Pickett Chuck Berry Bo Diddley etc etc
and let me quote 90% of them and this is
gonna piss you off because it disses me
off and I let them know it pisses me off
here's what they say and this goes back
to the 1960s
I'm glad you stand up for that stuff Ted
cuz I'm not gonna they'll never buy my
records again right how's that yeah I
was that for a bunch of spineless little
sackless wonders yeah but he drives me
nuts that's why the media and in
government and certainly academia has
gone so far left because nobody had the
balls to stand up and know that if you
smoke dope you're you're a liability who
do you want just Oh your pilot your baby
better how about your your glam scaper
who do you want hi in life and the
answer that is nobody it cures cancer
you fool learn the science here's no
tears believe me I've gotten into
arguments about this - I don't care what
people put in their body but I've not
seen positive
repercussions from people doing it
personally but there is a difference why
the discrepancy between a lot of new
rockers I'm gonna give you an example my
mother-in-law she toured with Aretha
Franklin Joni Mitchell Grateful Dead she
was a backup singer she left she's now
does like gospel she's just not as good
as it and I wouldn't just say this as
good as it gets my mother is an
award-winning wardrobe stylist she did
the big comedy Just for Laughs festival
all the french-canadian sitcoms so I was
raised in a family like cuz I've been
around creative people and artists even
at the highest level I mean at this
french-canadian show they create where
my mom would work for example one day
we'd have Eminem come in when he was at
the top the next day Moby he you know
but he was at he was he was really
popular at some point there is a there
is a disconnect there is definitely a
chasm between like you said those the
hard rocker seem to be distinctly
conservative as opposed to mainstream
rock the modern alternative rock and I
do have because good it's still a hard
work listen let's be honest even if we
don't like their music they still have
an incredible work ethic as Greg Gutfeld
says a lot of these Hollywood liberals
they don't act liberal in their own life
they only get by by an incredible work
ethic and they believe that they get
what they take but they don't espouse
that why do you think it is specifically
people like hard rockers is it [ __ ] is
it just the balls factors at the scrotum
factor do we go back to that well and I
again being slithering throughout the
inside all my life I mean literally I
started playing my guitar 60 years ago
and I had a band in Detroit we played
boogie woogie and honky Tonk it's a
Michigan State Fair in 1958 so I I've
been around the block a few in fact I
built the damn block blew the blocked up
and still went around it well that's a
that's every block in Detroit now
they're all blown up and another
fascinating angle that I guess no one
has ever admitted to is that you can't
be a success without busting your ass
just the schedule on the road even those
those [ __ ] that dude doesn't it take
two days off I mean my god I don't want
you to hurt yourself but anyhow here
here's one for you the insulation
during in the world of celebrity is what
killed Jimmy Hendrix and Elvis Presley
and Janis Joplin and Jim Morrison
I looked John Belushi in the eyes I
looked Keith Moon in the eyes I looked
Jimi Hendrix in the eyes when they
offered me their drugs and alcohol and I
went god it's you're killing yourself
Bob Scott made fun of me because I
wouldn't drink his jack with him and I
said bond
you son of a [ __ ] this is gonna kill
you man you are there you have a gift
you have a soul of musical projection
and an authority but you don't need this
Dianne talking about so the installation
should be wouldn't be sound like James
Nelson Reilly you don't know what you're
talking about yeah those don't love it
I'll be sound that's real good my point
is is that the insulation factor
nobody told Elvis you can't do that
nobody Oh Jimmy you can't do that I've
been trying to tell but I they kind of
laughed at me because I you know
presumed to be this right-wing Attila
the Hun wait let's not actually
presumption uh they just for summary
they were so strangled by the hipster
embracement of getting stoned and
drooling and puking and dying that they
just couldn't shake out of it and the
leopardy lie will so insulate you you'll
have your road manager you have your
your assistant I have road managers and
I have assistants but I tell them what
to do and I listen to them because Bob
Quandt Linda Peterson Doug banker my
team are my blood brothers they will
tell me when I'm doing something stupid
I'm just I'm waiting for them to and
because I've never done anything stupid
so what else the point is is that the
installation factor can all of a sudden
make you think that well we need to we
need to feed the hungry when in fact
most of the hungry are buying dope and
whiskey Mayer they spend it on nutrition
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lata with credit.com
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than six dollars a month
and you get daily content no more clips
Plus this hand etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside